Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are asking the question
should you switch with side
of the bed you sleep on?
Oh man.
And other questions.
I'm gettin', I got a shiver down my spine
when I heard you ask that and
when I immediately read it,
I was like, oh I feel threatened.
This is a question from a
Mythical Beasts in response
to a prompt that we put
out on, I don't know,
where do we put it out?
Twitter, Facebook, how do we do?
Twitter.
Follow us on Twitter.
Got a lot
of really good questions.
Follow us on Facebook.
Follow us on Instagram, follow us on--
Yeah follow us everywhere.
Follow us, follow us to
the ends of the earth.
Don't think, just follow.
So yeah I'm excited about that question
and a number of questions that we got.
So excited that we should just get right
into one of the questions.
Yeah let's do it, you feeling excited?
Well I am--
You don't look excited.
Well because I like to
ease into the thing.
People who--
It's early, still early.
People who come in and seem
too excited for the morning,
they burn out so fast.
I build up.
Are you talkin' about,
you thinking about somebody in particular?
No I would say that one out of eight days
you kinda do that and I can kinda see it
in your face, it's kinda
like, I gotta psych myself up.
I gotta psych myself up man,
and you come in and you're
psyching yourself up
and I can tell that you have
not had a good day so far.
So--
No.
No no no.
My theory about you is
that when you seem excited,
it's because--
I'm compensating.
You haven't had a good day.
It isn't because oh Link's
having a great time,
he's super excited.
He's in a great mood.
When you're having a good
day, I think you're like this.
Nothing.
Yeah.
Just flat line.
Yeah, right.
But if I'm not having a good day,
I seem like I'm having a great day.
Yeah and if I seem like
I'm having a great day,
I am having a great day.
I don't psych myself up.
That never happens, Rhett.
Right, no I'm having--
One out of every eight days,
I need to have a good day.
I work my way into a good day every day.
I like to have something
to look forward to,
not something to dwindle,
you know what I'm saying?
So set your expectations low
at the beginning of the day,
don't smile too much,
don't seem too excited.
Listen.
And by the end of the day,
you'll be happy.
There's another thing.
Sometimes you're right, okay.
I'm not gonna say you're wrong.
Often I'm right.
About this.
75% of the time I'm right.
I'm not talking about in general, you.
I'm talking about, yeah,
75% of the time you're right
about my one in eight
times I'm acting happy
when I'm not in order to become happy.
Okay good.
But there are times--
When you're just happy?
When I'm just frickin'
happy in the morning!
Like and it usually has to do
with some magical song came
on my playlist on my drive in.
Ah, you're too, yeah,
yeah, that's your problem.
Why does there gotta be a problem?
No I'm saying--
Just be happy for me
that I was happy.
Hold on,
here's what I'll say.
Oh don't get happy because of music.
If, no, music can make you happy
but if you know that music
can change your mood,
you should find the songs that do that
and you should make sure
that one of those is always
in the playlist.
No.
I don't want you to be happy
Link one out of eight times.
I want you to be happy Link all the time
if it's a possibility.
Now you're sounding like an addict.
'Cause here's the thing--
Are you addicted to music?
Happiness is not something
you can manufacture,
my brother, it's something
that when you do, it diminishes
but when a song, it's kinda
like when your favorite song
comes on the radio, it makes you happier
than when it comes on when
you scroll and select.
You're not listening to the radio though.
I'm not but I'm listening
to Spotify curated playlists
that they, the algorithm thinks I'll like.
So when the algorithm--
So you're relying
on the computer to make you happy.
Yeah, when the computer makes me happy--
Who's got the problem here?
I'm happier than when
I make myself happy.
But I'm in control.
Listen I'm not interested
in happiness, I'm interested in joy.
Fine, everything I was saying
I was talking about joy.
Joey, two syllables.
Joey.
Yeah, I wonder how Joey's doing.
You know you're in the
south when you don't know
whether someone is asking for Joy or Joey.
Joey.
Hold on, did you say Joy or
Joey because I couldn't tell.
Do we wanna start with the big question?
See, oh you're getting happy too soon.
It's too early for you--
No no no no no no.
For you to get to happy.
I'm letting natural circumstances,
much like a playlist, make me happy, okay.
I'm super excited about this question.
'Cause we didn't talk about this--
Well you're gonna burn out.
We didn't talk about this
because of the way that the
vacations worked and all this
but I really wanted to
know your opinion on this.
On this question?
I've talked about,
about my wife because
there was something related
to this that went viral on
Twitter so this question--
Read the question.
This is from Mike, @DadBodFL.
That's a good name.
My wife, out of nowhere,
eight years into our marriage,
decided she wanted to change what side
of the bed we sleep on.
Now especially in the
context of the question,
my wife, eight years into
marriage, decided she wanted
to change the side of the
bed she wanted to sleep on.
It sent shivers down my spine.
Oh I can only imagine.
Like I just felt, I had a
fear reaction of empathy
to you, @DadBodFL.
Now--
That dad bods all
of a sudden finding yourself
on the other side of the bed.
I think what I'm about to tell you--
But I don't wanna have a
knee-jerk, emotional reaction.
It's gonna blow your mind.
I wanna analyze this
and I wanna be open to--
Well, and I have a theory about the way
that you approach this
and I think you probably
have a theory about the
way I would approach this.
Now the reason I wanted to get
in this question is because
a few weeks ago on Twitter,
there was a guy, or a girl, I
don't know who it exactly was.
It was someone, I don't think
they were a public
personality, maybe they were,
anyway they were like, "Last
night we were hanging out
"with a couple that we've
been friends with for awhile,
"and we found out that
they do not have sides
"of the bed that they sleep on."
Wow.
"Any given night, they
may end up on either side
"of the bed and it's not a discussion
"and it just is the way
they've always been."
And of course--
Are they pass-out drunk
every night or something?
And this of course
sent shock waves throughout
the internet because
this is crazy, okay.
I personally think that,
and I'm a person that,
I'm not routine-oriented.
Yeah.
But this struck me--
Why?
As bonkers, you know.
Yeah.
The idea that you don't
have a side of the bed
because there's just so
many just utilitarian things
that go along with what side of the,
you've got bedside tables
that have your stuff
in them, right, you put your phone.
Preach, Rhett!
There's reasons to be
on a side of the bed.
Preach, now--
And so I--
'Cause you saying this,
it brings a lot more power
than me saying it because
everyone's gonna know
that I'm gonna say my thing about--
But hold on but let me just say
your opinion about that
is not a novel opinion.
That's a normal opinion
that someone would have
a bedside table that has,
like there's a drawer that is,
I'm not even an organized person
but I am an organized
person compared to my wife,
at least when you're
talking about drawers.
So I got things in my drawer,
I got books on my side.
I got the way I wanna charge
my phone et cetera on my side.
Now, the thing that I
discovered when Jessie
and I started talking about this
and this is my question to you is
have you always had a
particular side of the bed
throughout your whole marriage regardless
of what house you're in and
when you stay in a hotel,
do you occupy the same side of
the bed that you do at home?
That's my question for you.
And let me just say that my
guess is that you've always had
the same side of the bed
and you always assume it on vacation.
Maybe I'm wrong, maybe I'm presumptuous
but that's my theory.
I'm thinking back to all my beds.
Okay, yes, I've always,
throughout 19 years of marriage,
sleeping in the same bed for 19 years,
slept on what I'll call the left side,
so from my perspective
sleeping in the bed,
looking up at the ceiling, my
left shoulder is closest to,
is on the left side of it.
So the right side of the bed.
I think most people, you're sitting there,
you're looking at a
bed and there's a right
and a left side of the bed.
Well it's kinda like
stage left I think.
Like if you're about
to get in the bed.
When I get into bed,
I'm a performer, brother,
so I'm talking bed left.
Okay so bed left and I
would say room right.
Room right.
So as you're looking at
the bed and you're like
am I gonna sleep on the
left side of the bed
or the right side of the bed,
you sleep on the right side
of the bed.
I'm gonna sleep
on the right side
and then magically it
becomes the left side.
Okay.
So that's a bonus.
Okay, and this is something
that just happened early on
in your marriage and then there
was no reason to switch it.
Didn't think about it.
And the second part of your question,
when I go to a hotel room and
I'm traveling with Christy,
I have actively thought about this.
We have not discussed it.
But when you walk in the room
and you've got your luggage
and I immediately like to settle in.
I like to put the luggage,
I like to, if anything needs
to be hung I like to hang it.
I like to put the toiletries by the sink.
I like to settle in,
I like to feel secure.
But that involves going ahead
and kind of claiming a side
of the bed immediately.
Right.
And I don't wanna burden
Christy with this conversation.
Of course the flip side of that is,
you should consult your wife, she knows.
But we instinctively--
But she knows that
that's a dead end.
We go to the same sides and by the way,
whenever I'm traveling
alone, well, you know what,
it's up for grabs at that point,
but I do sleep on a side of the bed.
Well I think.
A side that you determine
to be most useful, this has
a better lamp on the side
or something.
You gotta reach your phone
or whatever.
There's a reason.
You gotta reach your phone.
It really has to do with if
there was a plug on one side
and I can get to charge my phone,
sometimes I don't have both sides.
Okay well I will say that
when I sleep in a hotel bed
by myself I sleep in the middle of the bed
because as a big man--
You can reach anywhere.
This is like what I
always want is a large bed
that I can just go anywhere.
And if you're in the
middle you can reach both
bedside tables simultaneously.
Easily.
Yeah I can put my hands on
both tables at the same time.
Finally, you got something to live for.
Now .
Jessie and I began to talk about this
and it led to an argument.
Oh.
Because--
Based on the tweets?
Yeah because, now first of all,
just to give you a lay of the land,
I started thinking back
through previous houses,
and in my previous home,
I slept on the other side of the bed.
And then I went back
and in the other house,
I slept on the same side
that I sleep on now.
And so there seems to
be no rhyme or reason
to which side I pick in a
particular house that we're in,
however, we stay on that side of the bed.
When we go on vacation, there
is no conversation about it
and we end up on either side of the bed
and we never talk about it--
It's random, just random.
It's just random if we're in a hotel.
Well, sorry, it's not random.
It could be either side
but when I started
evaluating the psychology,
realizing that I was the one
making the choice first--
Ah.
This is when she got mad.
You pointed it out to her.
I have a thought process
that's almost subconscious
that has been determining
which side of the bed I
sleep on in every environment
that I've ever slept on a bed.
Okay and what is it?
It is I want to be farthest from the door.
The door.
Oh you wanna put, you wanna use
your wife as a human shield.
So which that, hence the argument.
So what I told her is without
even thinking about it,
and it's not in and this is why she's mad,
it's not in relation to her.
It's not like I want her to protect me.
It's that I have this
instinctive and I've never been
in a room and had somebody
come in and attack me.
It's never happened in 41 years, right?
But I'm a cautious person.
I am--
Cagey.
I am the kind of person that
goes into a public situation
and thinks about where I'm
sitting in a restaurant
and that kinda thing.
I'm not a big worrier in that regard
and I don't seem anxious about
it but I feel like almost
in like a pseudo-tactical--
Jason Bourne?
Way, I'm kind of making,
not that I would be capable
of doing anything given the
extra couple of seconds.
I've only ever been in two
fights and they both ended
with me punching someone in the stomach.
You know what I'm saying, I'm
not a hand-to-hand combat guy.
I'm a lover not a fighter.
Well that's why you gotta
have more space to run.
But there's this thing that's like
I need some time to think.
Again, I'm not trying to evaluate,
'cause it's not a conscious process.
It's I always, without fail,
go to the side of the bed
or the bed, and I don't
know if you remember this,
like for a long time when we
traveled we would get two--
Double beds.
One room
and two double beds.
I would always pick the
one furthest from the door.
Now--
And I like that 'cause I
wanted to be further away
from the AC.
Right so it worked out
without even discussing it.
Which is usually on a window unit.
And Jessie was understandably
mad 'cause she was like,
I have a tendency to be,
like when we're out in public
and I start walking,
sometimes I'll just kinda
just walk ahead and just, 'cause I'm so,
I am not a very thoughtful person.
That's a pet peeve of
hers, you walking ahead.
And I walk very fast and she walks slow
and she thinks she walks
regular speed and I walk fast.
I think I walk fast and she's slow
but that's for another time.
Maybe you walk
the same speed but when
you factor in leg length--
Well we've had a lot of
leg length arguments,
let's just say that.
And she's got unusual
shoes a lot of times.
I don't.
She's got shoes with fish bowls in them.
What does this have to
do with the bed though?
It just means that it's
consistent with my tendency
to disregard her in her eyes.
Yeah so--
And so therefore--
You didn't defer to her--
She's like,
"You're not protecting me.
"You're putting me in the way
of the potential crazed person
"who will come in here
and try to kill us both."
Well and you're like,
somebody could come through the window.
Exactly, yeah.
But that's not what you think.
I'm not thinking at all.
That's just what
you're now arguing.
And now let me say this,
now that I am consciously
considering this,
I'm gonna be closest to the door now
because it isn't, I'm
not gonna sleep any less.
So as a physical demonstration
of love and deference,
you're going to sleep closer to the door.
I'm gonna put myself in harm's way.
You're gonna really--
For my wife.
Well okay.
But isn't that interesting
though that I had subconsciously chose
this side of the bed?
I've been interested
in it, yeah.
It's held my interest.
And then when I think
back about those other,
those previous houses, it was like, yes,
I'm always on the other side of the bed.
Is that, of the door?
Is the door--
Furthest from the door.
At home.
Because in your first
house, back in Fuquay,
I thought it had to do with something with
when you stood up to get out of your bed,
the roof angled to the point
where you could not stand up
in your own bed.
That would be--
'Cause that's a fact.
That would have been
either side of the bed
because in fact--
It had an A frame.
That side, that time in Fuquay
was completely arbitrary
because the house was, the
bedroom was a converted attic
and the door was equidistant--
A foot.
From the foot of the bed.
Well what about, what about
the one in Sherman Oaks?
Your California home where--
I was furthest from the door.
But the bed was against the wall.
I was against the wall.
So you had to climb over Jessie in order
to get in the bed if she got in first
and I think it's 'cause she
stayed up later than you.
I think that's the reason.
Well we talked
about this and she said,
"Well the reason we did it
"in that house is because I was getting up
"with the kids more often than you were."
Again, another point of disregard.
Lazy husband.
But I was like, "Yeah I mean
you're just so much better
"about getting in and out
of bed, you're small."
It takes me an extra
few seconds, you know.
Something could happen.
Anyway yeah so I'm not
gonna go into the details--
That's actually--
Of the argument that we had
but I have made the decision now that,
now that doesn't mean that
we're going to switch places
in our current home because
it's pretty established
at this point and I am
furthest from the door.
See I think the reason
why, I just don't have,
I don't have the door thing that you have.
For me when we travel and
we're sleeping together,
like when we're on vacation
and those three different beds
that we're staying in, I'm always
on what I'm calling the left
side which is the right side
of the bed, because as I'm sleeping,
she's moving on my right side.
There's a being over there.
And if the being's now,
I'm not used to a being on my left side.
And so that's gonna give
me a bad night's sleep
'cause subconsciously I'm
disoriented so having a bean
on the right side is normal.
Having it be on my left
side is discombobulating.
I don't think it's that
discombobulating but--
Oh it is.
And then you, you have more room,
you know where you have more
room subconsciously to roll,
like if I roll this way, I got more room.
There's gonna be a person
there but I'm not gonna roll
off the bed and I know that if I'm--
Yeah you're not a child,
you're not a toddler.
And you know what, as a matter of fact,
last night I just remembered--
I rolled off the bed.
I came as close as you could
come to rolling off the bed.
Yeah that hasn't happened
to me in many years.
And you know why?
Because on vacation, for over two weeks--
You had rails?
We been sleeping on king-sized beds.
I come back home to my queen-sized bed--
It's great, isn't it?
Yeah, I felt like--
I got a California king.
My subconscious was on a king-sized bed
and started rolling
over and I was teetering
and I woke up at a slide.
You probably should stick
to one side of the bed.
It seems safer.
Because to me, that's
what it all boils down to,
so back to Mike @DadBodFL's question,
for me I had a fear
reaction because I'm afraid
of rolling off the bed or at
least having compromised sleep.
I think that the size that you're used
to someone being on in the bed with you
makes a big difference
in your quality of sleep.
But I will say that--
I can't believe
your argument.
Well it might make
a big difference
for a couple of days.
Subconscious.
But I'm saying that I, again,
we have a slight difference
in philosophy about this.
I believe in continually shaking things up
so you don't become dependent
upon routine, right?
I could adapt.
'Cause you become
more flexible but in
this particular situation
in the context of a marriage,
this is in my mind, this
could be that your wife wants
to mix things up.
I mean this is a mild mixing.
But if she's like hey, we've been together
for eight years.
What are the next eight
years are gonna be like?
Well they're gonna be like
me being on the other side
of the bed for one.
That's potentially, just take it.
First of all, I think you should ask why.
You shouldn't ask us why,
you should ask her why
'cause we don't know.
You should find out is
there any underlying reason
or is it just like hey baby,
I wanted to shake things up
or no, actually, I
wanted to be further away
from the door so you would
be the one to get killed.
It could lead to arguments.
Or an intruder came in.
But again, it might lead to
some self-sacrificial action
like Rhett's doing.
But you make a good point
with mixing things up.
Because I am always gonna be a
proponent of mixing things up
when it comes to the bedroom.
I mean, hey, now we're onto something.
Okay I got your attention.
All right.
So this could be, things
could be getting exciting.
This could be like a little--
Yeah you never know
where this is gonna lead.
Here's what I'll say.
And you know what,
go for it.
I think, I wanna--
Just--
Before we move on--
Go down the water slide.
I want to acknowledge that--
Wee!
Now that I think about
which side of the bed
you consider the right
and left side of the bed,
you might have something here.
Because when you're in a car,
the right side of the car
is as referenced from
being inside of the car.
I didn't wanna tell you
but yeah, you're right.
But I feel like--
Because I'm right.
When you go, no, if you
go to a mattress store
and you ask a person selling mattresses,
"Touch the right side of the mattress."
What is the person selling
the mattress gonna do?
I think they're gonna touch the right side
of the mattress as if
you're looking at the bed.
I agree but it's not his mattress.
So you think it changes once
it becomes your mattress,
or changes once you get in the bed?
When it becomes your bed, your mattress.
Talking about mixing things up,
I mean you're really shaking me with that.
I mean I sustained injuries from sleeping
on the same side of the bed for too long.
I would sleep on my right side.
That was sleeping on the
wrong side of your body,
not the side of your bed.
I would spoon Christy
but I would use my arm,
I'd put my right elbow up
next to my right ear and
I would use my own elbow--
As a pillow.
As a pillow
and I did that for so long that the bones
in my shoulder started to
grind against each other
and wore down the frickin'
cushion and now, I have--
Technical term.
I have pain there
and so, I learned to sleep on my back
and I can't spoon anymore
but the solution could be
wear down the left shoulder.
You can spoon.
I could get spooned.
You could spoon,
but you can't spoon asleep,
but you can spoon just for fun.
It still hurts.
Or I think it's hurting.
There's no spooning now?
I think, I can't spoon because I think
that I'm grinding my shoulder
and so I actually try
to keep my elbow down by
my hip and spoon that way.
The thing about me--
And that's just weird.
The thing about spooning for me--
It's like you're upright
but you're laying down.
Is I've always only
ever been the big spoon
because if I'm the
little spoon with Jessie,
it's like I have a backpack
on, you know what I'm saying?
It's just not the same sensation.
You're an ultra large little spoon.
Shall we move on?
I just wanna make sure
we got closure here.
We've told him he needs
to talk to his wife about
this but then take it
as an opportunity.
Ironically,
you know what I'm gonna do tonight?
I'm gonna get in bed
first, I'm gonna get in
on Christy's side and I'm
not gonna say anything.
Yeah that's not gonna work.
I'm gonna go all the way to sleep
and then see if she wakes me up.
If you move the furniture it might work.
Move all the stuff in there.
Yeah.
I think Christy and I, all
right I'm audible here.
Maybe we need to throw it
in the mix to switch it up.
Yeah, see how it feels.
Let's both, let's both
do that with our wives
and then report back.
Let's talk 'em, Jessie,
she won't care, right?
Mm, I don't know, I gotta
talk to her about this.
We can't decide right now for 'em.
Listen if I've learned anything,
I'm not gonna make a decision on a podcast
that affects my wife.
We're gonna begin
negotiations which may lead
to a trial period of sleeping
on other side of the bed
and see what happens.
Yeah, mix it up.
But I guarantee you there'll
be some bad nights' sleep.
Not for me.
No I'm being honest with you.
I know for a fact it's
not going to affect,
'cause I do it randomly when
we travel and it's never--
Thanks Mike for--
So we got more questions but
first we wanna let you know
that you can go to Mythical.com
and you can pick up one
of these Snotebooks.
It's a notebook, it's a
sketchbook, it's both,
that's why it's a Snote.
This one's Jenna's,
she's been, oh she got,
there's a lot of things,
got her number in there.
Got the GMM logo on one.
E-mail just in case
it's lost.
You got the Randler logo,
hold it up by your face
so that it can be in the shot, my brother.
So one of these was designed
by our very own Kaitlyn.
Was that this one?
It was both of 'em.
Both of 'em?
That makes it easy.
Yeah she did both of 'em.
Okay, she did both of 'em, wow.
Artsy.
Mythical.com.
Writing stuff down is powerful,
it's good for your brain,
it's good for your life experience
and I like knowing that
we're a part of that.
So buy it.
Here's another question
from @scienceisanart.
Huh.
I moved in with my
boyfriend a few months ago
and he has apparently never washed a dish
or cooked anything more
complicated than ramen in his life.
Okay.
Apparently spaghetti
is too complex for him
so what most basic dish
can I teach him to introduce into cooking?
Let me say that last part in
a way that makes more sense.
So what basic dish can I teach him
to introduce him to cooking?
Okay.
Well you know for me, I'm not a cooker.
I'm not a cheffer, I'm
not a maker of dishes.
I'm not proud of that
but it's just a fact.
Nothing about learning how to
cook has ever appealed to me.
And again, it's almost a confession
but you already know that.
I am however a cleaner.
So I'm observing right off the bat--
So you like the part that no one does.
You pick the only thing
that, part of the process
that nobody likes.
Well the way that I've
always justified it,
and Christy enjoys cooking
sometimes, not all the time,
but because I don't enjoy cooking at all,
if someone's gonna cook,
it's on her until now the
kids have gotten old enough
to start preparing things themselves,
especially Lily who also
enjoys cooking and baking
to a large extent.
So I've always felt guilty
that she's been expected
to do the cooking and
not in like a masculine,
feminine role type way but just
in a personal taste kinda way.
Honestly I believe that's why.
Not because she's the woman or anything.
But I felt bad about that but
I've always compensated her
taking a defensive stance
of, well at least I'll clean.
Like hey, I made a decision
early on in our marriage
because I didn't know how to
cook and for whatever reasons
which I can go into if you want me to.
I've said, I'm just
gonna take the stance of,
I'm gonna be grateful and
uncritical of anything
that you wanna prepare because
I know that I would die
if you didn't do it, and
I will also then clean up.
So I think I got a good track record.
I'm not gonna say a great one
because my wife's probably listening.
But at least a decent track
record of at least compensating
with not cooking by cleaning.
You also like cleaning.
And I like cleaning.
I like putting things
away and a lot of people
who enjoy cooking, they start to say,
and Christy has said in the past,
and I've heard chefs as
I've spoken with many chefs,
it's like, the only part I hate
about cooking is the cleaning.
It's like well let me take care of that.
As an offering of gratitude.
But this guy does neither
and I find it interesting
that the thing that she's asking about is,
she's keying in on the cooking part
and maybe that's 'cause
she likes the cleaning part
so I respect that but now I'm a little out
of my league because--
Well let me ask you this.
So I'm just telling, buddy,
he should do one or the other.
Well I think maybe you
could speak to this.
So first of all, it is
interesting that you don't cook,
right, I think if you were
to analyze not personality,
but if you were to analyze background,
I was raised in a very traditional home
where my mom did all the household duties.
My dad couldn't cook anything,
wouldn't cook anything.
He basically--
He'd grill a steak.
Yeah he was the grill
man, he was the grill man.
He'll grill a steak, he'll
barbecue the chicken,
but it's basically, I
don't know what it is
about baby boomer men but it's like
I'm only gonna cook if I'm outside.
The moment that I come in it's like
this isn't my territory.
Lots of reasons for that.
And so, my mom did everything for us.
Like, my brother and I never did laundry.
I think she was just like, you guys,
she didn't have the patience
for us to make the mistakes
that we would have made.
She was just like, "Just
let me do that," you know,
and that's kind of a baby
boomer mom kind of thing
in a lot of ways.
So going into college,
I never cooked anything.
But I liked to eat so much
that there came a time
in which I was like,
I have to cook for myself.
It wasn't like, I wanna be a cooker.
You know, it was like I
want to cook so I can eat.
And I love it and--
So in our dorm room,
we had one of those toaster oven things
and I don't recall using that much.
Not really cooking, even
if I were to use it but--
So then you're referring to
when we got our first
apartment that had a kitchen.
Yeah and--
You started cooking stuff.
Yeah and also, Greg
could cook a little bit.
Tim could cook a little bit.
We all kinda could cook a
little bit but it was like,
okay I'm gonna make Hamburger Helper.
I'm gonna make mashed
potatoes out of a box.
But you never, you were like I'll eat it
but you never were like,
I'm gonna make the Hamburger Helper.
I'm gonna fry up the hamburger.
Well you know what,
Rhett there's a saying.
It goes a little something like this.
Too many cooks in the kitchen.
I mean there's four guys
livin' in an apartment,
three of 'em are cooking in the kitchen.
Well no but here's the thing, we would--
There was also the laundry
was in the kitchen.
We would divide up the cooking.
It would be like tonight
Greg is gonna make this
or tonight Tim is gonna make it,
tonight Rhett is gonna make it
but there was never a tonight
Link is gonna make it.
That never worked into the mix.
But I find it interesting.
We never talked about it, I didn't care.
I have no ill will about it.
But you were actually on your own a lot.
Yeah.
Greg being raised
by a single mom and
being home alone a lot,
like you could have
cooked a lot of things.
You know what--
So why didn't you?
I think maybe--
'Cause you gotta get
into this guy's head.
I think that plays into it
because I think my mom,
because she had so many demands
on her life and feeding
me being just one of 'em,
I think it was like,
anything that was pre-made
at the grocery store we needed to get.
We needed, she didn't have
the time or the energy
to cook as much so let's
work with that theory
because I, fact.
Everything in our house was like,
you pull up the foil top
and then you can just,
you eat it with a spoon.
Applesauce, pudding.
All the best things.
And then bars, you can
just open up and eat.
Or cookies.
But you didn't eat bars
for dinner.
I mean she always cooked when I came over.
She wouldn't--
She had that stove top--
Skillet.
Skillet thing
that you put on the counter, yeah.
Yeah she had her, we talked about
in the Book of Mythicality,
she had her few meals
that she would, she'd serve--
Rotation, yeah.
She had the rotation.
I don't know, maybe that has
something to do with it though
is that a lot of it was stilL packaged
and I was, I would be
home alone for lunches
over the summer and I remember
my favorite thing was,
you'd peel the top off of this package
that would have roasted chicken legs
from like Holly Farms or
whatever it was called.
Roasted, fully cooked chicken legs
and I wouldn't even eat 'em
hot, I would just eat 'em cold.
It's like so easy.
Right.
So it's like it's so easy,
it's so tasty.
I was rewarded.
Why go through effort when
I gotta do is rip the top
off of this thing?
That's what I learned as a child.
Just rip the top off, brotha.
Get to something else.
Like playing cards by
yourself in your room,
looking at your G.I. Joes.
Yeah I mean, to me,
so I think that when
you think about cooking,
there is no joy, the joy of cooking.
I've never experienced it.
Ironically, I mean, when
I took that cooking class
in Thailand, I started, I was like oh,
I had this knife for a
second, I was chopping stuff
and I actually, he made the
meal and then we made it.
It's like I could see
how this could be fun
but it felt like an entirely
new experience to me,
like I never experienced the fact
of putting stuff together and also,
I think there's anxiety
of having never done it,
it's like all I'm gonna
do is screw this up.
There's no way this is gonna work.
Fear of failure.
There's a lot of steps,
there's a lot of things to get
right and if I'm gonna do it,
I gotta do it exactly right.
I think maybe--
So it's a lot of pressure.
I think maybe 'cause cooking
versus baking--
It's not an art to me.
Baking is more probably
your style because it's like
all these specific ingredients
and specific temperatures--
But it's too intimidating to get
into the exactness of that.
I feel that way about all of it.
All right so maybe this will
help with your boyfriend.
'Cause from my perspective,
the reason I like doing it
and I don't do it that often.
I usually, the weekends
is when I have time to,
I've got time, you know.
I get home probably seven o'clock and so,
and sometimes Jessie gets
home at the same time
and then we'll either do take-out
or we'll eat something late.
We're not one of those families
that eats at the same time.
We eat somewhere between
six o'clock and nine o'clock
and you never know when it's gonna be.
But the thing that I like
about it is I do like building
and creating things.
I've never done it but the
idea of making a sculpture
or painting a painting, getting
into something like that
that there's a process and
then there's a final product
has always been intriguing to me.
I think it's one of the
reasons I like what we do.
But the beauty in cooking is
that you get to do the process
and then you get to eat the final product.
So it's better than art
because you get to eat it.
I love to eat so much.
It's one of
your favorite things.
If I could paint a painting
and then eat it.
That would be incredible.
So what you're getting at for me and him,
'cause this is also--
You gotta find something
you can connect with
in the process.
You gotta find the joy.
Where's the joy?
For you it's the art
of creation and then the art of consuming.
The art of creation and
the exercise of consuming,
of tasting.
And there is a sense
of accomplishment that I'm
not gonna make something
that's as good as what we can
get take-out in Los Angeles,
most likely.
But I did it, man.
I'm eating the art that I made.
And so yeah but back to--
Like a child
eating Play-Doh.
Back to her username,
@scienceisanart, ironically.
Maybe we're onto something
that can help you tap
into his passion because, you know,
you're a little divisive in
the way you've written this.
Apparently spaghetti
is too complex for him.
You've gotta lose the 'tude, first of all.
Just because he doesn't like cooking,
it's just like the stuff
you don't like doing.
You're not gonna shame him into cooking.
But I think--
But you can
lure him into it.
What's the best dish,
'cause the first thing that
comes to mind is grilled cheese.
I think that you cook stuff together--
'Cause grilled cheese is
a sandwich which is easy
but it's a slightly cooked sandwich.
With every step of cooking
the grilled cheese,
you take off an article of clothing.
You know?
Make it a little--
Make it a bedroom--
Make it foreplay.
Mix it up again.
You can do this on either
side of the kitchen.
Right.
Which you always use
the same burner, use a different burner.
There's a saying, Rhett.
And this is how it goes.
Lovemaking starts in the kitchen.
I agree with that.
So that's another one.
One may be art, another may
be bribery, I don't know.
I'll give you an Amazon
gift card if you learn how
to make spaghetti.
Again, that's not a good idea.
Well the specific question
was what's the most basic dish?
I don't know, I'm not putting
a lot of thought into this.
I don't think it's about
how basic the dish is,
it's not about the dish being easy,
it's about tapping into motivations.
Yeah I agree with that but
you gotta start somewhere so--
Well I think that's a secondary,
you can't answer that question,
you can't give him grilled
cheese until you've come
to motivation because the motivation--
Yeah you gotta address the motivation.
Oh it needs to be beef stroganoff.
Maybe just get, make a
painting and let him eat it.
And if you're taking off the clothes,
you can call that beef take it off.
Oh.
Clothes.
Make it a game.
That's a good recipe.
It's a whole book.
Beef take it off.
Give me another question.
Oh we're really nailin' 'em this morning.
Mariah Bozzell.
@MCBozzell on Twitter, I
drive my friends crazy talking
over them all the time.
I just get so excited!
Tips for being a less
obnoxious conversationalist.
This hits a little close to home.
What do you mean?
Well considering that
not too many pods ago,
we talked about this.
However you can't in fact--
Then it's stupid for hunters
to not wear orange.
Hold on.
Why are there so many hunters--
Let me get this out.
The second thing is, one time--
But I've seen hunters not wearing orange.
Yeah 'cause let me just
finish the damn sentence, man.
It's more than one sentence.
The point--
It's multiple sentences.
And my theory was--
And I'm not gonna do that
joke where I interrupt you
because it's played out.
My theory was that you interrupt me
more than I interrupt you.
And it got a little prickly.
And then you what?
You gave an assignment.
No I just said, okay
somebody make a compilation,
and we actually talked to
Kiki, @youresoloud about this
when we met her at VidCon.
After she had answered your call.
She made a video that was a
series of you interrupting me
and most of the time saying,
"Sorry to interrupt,"
when you did it.
It was not an exhaustive compilation.
No it wasn't, it wasn't.
I think it was funny that
she answered your call
and it was all in good fun
and I found it humorous.
But listen, I mean, for that one,
she did some kind of search.
There was some sort of
search with interrupting.
And so what she did was,
I think all she proved
was that when I interrupt
you because I do,
I apologize for it and I use the word
I'm sorry for interrupting
so it's easier to find it
in some sort of like transcript search
and you don't apologize
but you do it just as much.
Okay and this is--
Question mark.
Oh, huge question mark.
Listen now, don't get super defensive.
I'm not.
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep
breathing in through my nose,
out through my mouth.
And I'm not mad about this.
We've actually talked
about this in the past.
Because first of all--
And let's have,
I just interrupted you.
I'm sorry for interrupting you
but I'm gonna have a real conversation
and I'm not gonna do any
for comedic effect anymore.
From this moment on, we're having a real--
Real conversation.
Sincere conversation about
interrupting each other.
Okay I think there's a couple of things.
We both like to talk.
We both like to hear ourselves talk.
This is a recipe for interruptions.
I do it and you do it.
And I think that who does it more
does have something to do with what it is
that we're talking about at the time.
If I get passionate about something
and I feel like I've got a lot
of important things to say about it,
I will be more likely to interrupt
and I guess the same holds true for you.
All that being said, there is a phenomenon
and this is where the whole
apologizing about interrupting
doesn't really come into play
and I don't really know
how often you do this
in the context of us
just being on a podcast
or even on the show.
But this is the thing
we talked about before.
You interrupt a lot
and you don't know that
you've interrupted.
So you're not being rude on purpose.
And the way that it happens most often is,
we're in a conversation
either together or most often,
in the context of a larger
group and we both begin talking
at, well, usually what happens is I start,
when this particular thing happens,
I start talking and I
get one to four words out
and then you just start talking.
And then my personality
is pretty deferential
in those circumstances so
I tend to stop talking.
You don't even know
that I started talking.
It isn't like I don't care
about what Rhett has to say,
I'm gonna start talking.
My theory is is that--
Well I can tell you
what happens.
The way that your brain
kinda works is that--
So it's not a theory.
Yeah, I think in like
meetings type of thing
or when we're making
decisions, we're processing,
so it's not like shooting the breeze.
I think you're really talking
about when we're in...
I'm not just gonna say
a business conversation
but a strategic or something that's like,
there's a lot of moving parts, I tend to,
I think and then speak
about it a little slower,
so I'll be a beat behind and then,
but I'll be thinking intently
and forming my thought
and so someone may have started talking
but those two words that
you said I didn't hear
because it was, I was still
in the silence of about to speak.
I would say it happens between
20 and 40 times a week.
I'm not exaggerating.
But it's just kinda
become a part of the way
that we interact.
Do you agree
that it's like in the office,
kinda like in meetings?
I think it's in any group conversation.
You think it's any shooting the breeze.
Any conversation, any group conversation.
So there was, a couple years ago--
This is an intervention.
So there's, no.
We've talked about it before,
there was a couple years ago
where I made a decision
that what I was going to do
when it happened was, I was
just going to not stop talking.
Because I'm, I know I'm an, trust me.
But I'm actually,
I'm a little too nice
in certain situations
and so I am very deferential,
my personality is
to be pretty deferential.
If there's two people
walking down the sidewalk,
I'm gonna be the one who
moves and says, "Excuse me."
Right, that's kinda, I tend
to do that almost to a fault.
So my natural disposition
is, he started talking,
I'm gonna stop talking.
So I try to do a thing where
I would start saying something
and then you would start talking
and I would just talk a little bit louder
and then it just didn't work.
Well I don't remember you doing that
but I can only imagine that
that would just make me angry
'cause why is he talking,
why is he yelling
when I was talking?
Welcome to the club.
But I still cannot believe
that if you're saying I do
this 20 to 40 times a week,
I cannot believe that.
It's a fact.
I cannot believe it.
I'm not exaggerating.
And so--
But I know that
you don't know it because you're not,
'cause I know that you
wouldn't do it intentionally.
So it's just kinda become a thing, this--
Don't know what.
Don't know that you had started talking.
Right?
Yeah but you'll notice
and you probably hear this from me.
I would say a couple of times a month,
especially if I'll be like,
"Hold on, I'm talking."
You'll hear me say that, right?
Hold on, hold on a second, I'm talking.
That's when I feel like
what I need to say needs
to be said right now.
Most of the time I'm
like what I need to say
can probably be said
after Link finishes saying
what he's gonna say.
That's typically what I do.
So my theory is that as
it might translate into,
again, it's very different in this context
because I'm in year ear on a microphone.
I don't think what we're
talking about now applies
to Ear Biscuits.
I don't think it does either.
So I do wanna talk about that
which is what I thought
we were gonna talk about.
But we need to come up
with a plan for this
because I cannot believe that
it's 20 to 40 times a week.
I just can't believe it.
And if that's true,
I want to know, but there's gotta be--
Do I need a bell?
Ding!
No there's gotta be,
there's gotta be a way that
doesn't involve a bell.
How about you wear a shock collar.
Oh you can't start making jokes.
We said we weren't making
jokes, this is serious.
Okay, all right, okay.
I'm just saying there's
gotta be a gentle way,
a gentle and private way for you to say,
or you know what, it can't be private
'cause there's someone
else in the conversation.
It doesn't happen when we're
just talking to each other,
it happens when the two of us
are talking to somebody else.
Right?
It happens but you do it
with other people in the office as well
but they all do what I do,
they just stop talking.
They stop talking 'cause
the boss is talking.
I stop talking because
I'm not willing to--
I honestly don't know
what's happening because--
I already knew, I already know.
It's because of the way,
it's exactly what you said.
What you explained is
you're not a rude person.
It is, he didn't, he was thinking
about what he was gonna say
and you tend to not listen
when you're thinking about
what you're gonna say
and so you're not hearing me speak.
But it's when there's a silence
and then it's like, it's the
kickoff of the conversation,
so it's not like you've
been talking and talking
and talking and then all
of a sudden I interrupt
in the middle.
Again, those are the type of things
that happen on Ear Biscuits.
Sometimes it might happen
that way if there's a pause.
But the theory is that--
And I was gonna continue.
If there's a pause,
and then it's like oh now is
a socially acceptable
opportunity for someone else,
potentially me, to speak,
so I'm going to speak
but I'm gonna need to
formulate what I need
to say because up until this
point I've been listening.
I haven't been formulating a thought.
It's like, it's not that
extreme but I think so linearly
that I live my life so linearly
that maybe not that extreme
but I do think that
happens where it's like
I am listening and then there's a pause
but I haven't been thinking
about what I'm gonna say so--
Well you've got two
modes because you have a,
you're actually much more
likely to speak your thoughts,
to speak without thinking than I am
and that's a certain
mode and you tend to be
in that mode when we're
entertaining which I would say
this is entertainment, hopefully.
And then also on the show
so it doesn't really happen
in that situation.
But the real life version
of that is that I'm a verbal processor.
So sometimes I don't
know exactly what I think
about something until I
begin to speak it out.
So I don't say things definitively,
I say things explanatorily.
That's how I speak.
Which ironically would make
you, lead you to believe
that I could fill a gap
immediately because I don't know
what I'm gonna think,
I verbally process it.
So those things don't
work totally together
but I do think my theory is,
'cause what I'm getting
at ultimately is some way
that you can gently
flag that it's happening
so that I can be
receptive to the feedback,
so that I can get better
about it, if you're right.
You're not making this up.
But it's that hard for me to believe
that it happens 40 times a week.
Well 40 times a week would
be eight times a day.
I said 20 to 40.
I would have been fine
with once or twice a day.
This seems like a lot more than that.
I think it depends on how many
of those conversations we're
in but anytime we're in a--
One out of how many conversations?
If we sit down and have a meeting
where we're both speaking about something,
it is going to happen.
Okay, I don't like that.
But I'm saying, in my
defense I do think that
it's most likely to happen at
a point where there's a pause
in the conversation
and then in that pause,
I'm formulating something,
someone else begins to speak,
but in my formulation
I still feel like I'm
in the gap and then I
start talking a beat later.
'Cause I do know another
thing that happens is
we're in a meeting and we've been asked
to make a decision about something
or give creative feedback
on something and then you'll,
one or both of us will give feedback,
then there'll be a pause and
then the person who's talking
to us like Stevie will then
move onto the next thing
and then halfway through her
moving onto the next thing,
I say one more thing about the last thing
because I'm still thinking about it.
And I realize that.
You know that
you're doing that 'cause you say, "Sorry,
"before we move on."
And I do that a lot.
I do know that.
I would say that if we're
in a meeting where there are seven items,
three of those items you're
gonna have an additional thought
and I actually--
And it would be weird
for her to have a twice
as long pause or ask me,
"Do you have anything else?"
'Cause that would be demeaning.
Let me say, I don't mind, I actually,
it's annoying.
What you just said, that
situation's not even annoying,
it's like that's how your brain works
and you are kinda the details
guy and the second check
and that kind of a thing and that's part
of our process so I welcome that.
It can be a little, it
sometimes can be like okay,
we just talked about that.
We got a bunch of the things.
I get it.
So it can be a little
annoying but it's not really.
Even the first thing
that we're talking about,
I would say that I am so
used to dealing with it
that it's only annoying
to me if I'm already
a little mad about something at you
and then I'm like mm,
he's doing that thing,
but it's not really, it's kinda like,
this is just the way,
I know he doesn't know,
he's not interrupting me
'cause he doesn't think what I said,
he doesn't know that he interrupted me.
He doesn't know that I started to speak
and then he started to speak so
if you want to deal with it,
I am open to dealing with it
but I'm saying that you
don't have to deal with it
because A, I don't know if it's possible.
But you're saying I do it to other people.
Yeah but everybody, I think also,
I would say that most
everyone else also knows
that you don't, maybe they
think you just don't care
what they have to say but
that's a good question.
I think most people who get to
know you personally are like,
oh, he's not, okay.
He's not being dismissive.
I just think maybe he didn't hear me.
I think most people would,
who are here long enough
would be smart enough to know that.
Do you think I'm right
that it's at the beginning
of conversations, at the end of gaps?
It is when, yeah,
but that gap could be someone is speaking
and there was a pause and they
wanted to continue speaking
but you started talking and then they,
so if I was saying something
and I was making a point
and then I said it and then I stopped,
but then I started going
again and after but then,
you started talking.
It does happen in that
situation but it is,
when you perceive a gap,
you don't just interrupt
people willy nilly.
It's you think there's
a gap or there is a gap
whether it's within a
person's conversation
or it's in a group conversation.
And am I contributing, 'cause
here's the funny thing is
I actually observe in other
people and I've been frustrated
by other people who I
think have a tendency
to when there's a gap in a conversation
they change the subject.
It's like oh they've been thinking about
what they wanted to say
and when they said it,
it had nothing to do with
what that person was saying
and then they just started,
so they changed the subject
to whatever they wanted to talk about
and that's something that irks me
so I find it weird
that, is that what I do?
No.
Okay because I do see,
when I see the people who do that,
I'm like I do not want to do that.
So okay, so I don't do
that, so I'm still--
No you're not changing the subject.
And I've also noticed--
You're speaking to
whatever we're talking
about but you're doing it
after someone else started speaking.
The only issue is that in the context
of these conversations, it is not unusual,
in fact it's rather
common for someone else
to begin speaking and
then two to four words
after they start, you start talking.
That is explicitly what it is.
Because I also notice when other people,
if somebody has a gap
in their conversation
but they're in the middle of a point
that they haven't completely made,
and then they give, they start talking,
that does frustrate me 'cause
when I see other people do that.
It's like well they're
not, I was following them
and they haven't made their point yet,
but you're saying I do that.
Well yeah, I think there
definitely are times
when you're like, but it isn't--
He was obviously
halfway done.
Hold on.
Not fully done and Link started talking.
But what you're doing
is, for whatever reason,
you are not listening
to, you're not tracking.
If you're tracking with somebody,
you're tracking with somebody.
Yeah.
It's when you've made a decision
that you're gonna say
something, you're thinking,
and sometimes it'll be like,
okay this person's saying something
but you're thinking about
what you're gonna say
because you're engaging with it
and so that point you're
not, I think it's you don't,
and this is where I'm like
I honestly don't know,
you might need to just be,
I don't know what you could do about it.
I don't know if you, you
can't change your ability--
This is why I need a flag.
Your ability to listen
while you're thinking.
I need a flag.
If your brain works in a certain way.
We're gonna have to look at examples.
So I need a symbol, I need
like, you just take your fist
and then put your pinkie up
and put it over your right nipple.
That's awkward.
And then I'll know,
I'll know that I did it
and then I'll say, okay,
why did I do that?
That's why I did it and
I'll be able to explain
to myself and to you and if I need
to change something, I can,
but I'm gonna need that feedback.
I think maybe we--
And it's gonna need
to be a pinkie.
I think maybe there should
just be a word.
And it can't be, you just did it.
Red light.
But there's other people in the room,
you can't just be like...
I just don't,
I wanna equip you so that
I'm receptive to this.
I don't know what it's gonna be.
Because if I'm gonna interrupt somebody
and then you're gonna interrupt
me for interrupting them
and what, tell them to go ahead?
It needs to be a physical symbol.
Do you think it needs
to happen in the moment
or do you think after
the conversation's over
I can be like, let me tell
you that these are a couple
of times that you did that thing.
When I was saying this or
when Stevie was saying that.
What do you think would be more helpful?
If it's right after the meeting.
'Cause I want to assure you--
It's gotta be right
after the meeting.
I'm not doing this for me.
I'm doing this for you--
It's gotta be fresh.
If you want it to be done because--
Well I don't think, did you
know you were gonna do this
when we were talking about it?
'Cause that's an intervention.
I didn't know I was gonna talk about it
until I saw the question.
I wasn't like, I need to
talk to Link about this.
'Cause we kinda talked
about this a few years ago
but we were talking
about, we tend to like,
this is one of the keys to our friendship,
I think we check in with each other.
That's why we're in a
relationship with each other.
What did we decide when we check,
you told me--
We were talking about
a lot of different things
and I think I just threw
in there, "And you always interrupt me."
Okay that was a low priority.
I don't think that it was constructed,
but we've been pretty
successful in friendship
and in business with
this phenomenon existing
and so I'm not angry about it.
I'm just saying that this is--
I don't feel like you're angry about it.
I feel--
But I do think it's
interesting that maybe other people are
because I know you so well that I know
that you're not actually interrupting me
but maybe other people are like,
he interrupts me all
the time, I don't know.
I'm gonna schedule meetings
with every employee
and I'm gonna ask 'em.
Now there are times when I
intentionally interrupt people
in a meeting when I feel
like we need to move on
or I get what you're saying
or so there are times
when I exercise the position of,
well I can dictate the
pace of this conversation
because this meeting's for me.
And when you do that,
you acknowledge that you're doing it.
So I don't think that's an issue.
Right, so it's like, I'm not gonna,
but I don't wanna lessen,
I don't want people
to think I'm doing it when I'm not.
It's disturbing to find out
that you've done something
apparently 20 to 40 times a week
that you're oblivious to.
So it's just disturbing
and I like to, you know,
yes.
Did you suggest putting up the pinkie?
No that was me.
No you did.
After every meeting, I'm
gonna say, "Did it happen?
"Tell me when it happened."
My theory--
I have to know.
Well my theory is that--
Does that work?
Yeah, my theory is that
at least initially, you're
gonna go in a conversation
in the next, in the coming
days and weeks thinking
about this and so it's probably gonna be,
it may go away completely
for a period of time.
When it comes back, I'll let you know.
I'm gonna ask after every meeting.
If it comes back, if it
comes back, I can have hope
then I'll let you know
but it may not happen
when you're just going into like,
I know that this thing happens,
I didn't realize it happened
but now I'm thinking about it.
Just an awareness could
be all that you need.
Okay, now to shift over in the interest
of wrapping up this conversation--
Yeah.
But I do wanna shift over
to the Ear Biscuits dynamic
which I think nothing that
we've talked about applies
because we're in a performance
mode when we're both talking
and I do acknowledge
that there is an element
of the way that, there are
times when I'll interrupt
that I thought was more part of the way
that this show worked
that interrupting each
other was part of it,
that then through the
feedback of listeners,
I'm like hmm, it's actually
having an annoying effect
or a frustrating effect.
Like if you're in the middle of something
that you're really passionate about,
there was a point in the past,
not currently, in my mind
where I thought that my role
in the entertainment quotient
of the conversation was
to quip and interject and sometimes just
to throw in some things when
you were going on a monologue
and then I think I expected
you to do the same thing.
Now I may not have reacted
in a positive way to it
because I may not have been
capable of staying on task
in my monologue if you were to do it to me
and maybe you, I'm
throwing out theories here,
maybe you knew that so you didn't do it
but if you were to have asked me,
I would have described
the conversation climate
of Ear Biscuits to be that
we are both constantly
interrupting each other
and it's like there's kind
of a barrage of those things
and in the middle of a passionate point,
we may go off on this
big, long rabbit trail
because somebody said something.
We may get in an argument
or have a laugh attack
or go way off and then
we come back eventually
and that's kind of a entertainment mode
of what Ear Biscuits is.
I think we both do that.
I think we do it in different ways
and I think this is why it's perceived,
I think there's two factors,
'cause again, this is theoretical.
But I've also, the second
half of my point was
I've changed my mind about that.
Okay , okay.
Well okay--
So I'm saying that's how
I did think but then just
to get my complete point out there,
people were annoyed by me interrupting
and so I am making a conscious effort
over the past few months of doing it less.
I've literally tried to put my hand
over my mouth, okay
Rhett's making a point.
He cares about this.
It would be frustrating
if I kept interrupting.
It wouldn't be entertaining.
For some reason I thought
it was but it's not,
so I'm gonna just, so I've actually,
I've been trying to interrupt less.
I can say I have noticed that.
But I don't think that
your instincts were wrong.
I think that we interrupt
in different ways.
And I think that again,
neither one of us have ever
taken an improv class, right,
but obviously the yes and
principle is something
that is true to improv and I
think that as we have a lot
of chemistry and we have a
lot of comedic chemistry,
but your disposition is not yes and.
It just isn't yes and, that's not,
there's nothing about
Link Neal that is yes and.
There's a lot of but what or--
Yeah.
And--
Or totally, or left field.
You bring in, whereas you
might be telling a story
and you'll notice that the
way that I kinda interject
into a story that you're
telling is I'm like yep,
mm-hmm, or little joke here,
in a certain tone and again,
and I think it has something to do
with being raised in a bigger family
where people were telling
stories and you're interjecting
and that kinda thing.
And you tend to do the same
thing but when you do it,
it's more derailing than
a yes and kinda thing.
So again, it's part of who you are.
I haven't, it may be annoying
to an audience member at times.
It's not personally annoying to me.
Yeah I'm talking about them.
I think the feedback has
been helpful, that's like,
if you're making a point
and you're obviously getting
at something and I'm engaged.
I know what you're
getting at but I feel like
what normally could take eight minutes,
it would be better if it took 16 minutes
because that additional eight minutes
of something unexpected or...
Fill in the blank, it just adds
to the entertainment factor
but now I understand that
an eight minute story
that you gotta wait an
additional eight minutes
to get to the point,
it's also frustrating.
So there's a middle ground
of like if you're gonna add
a minute of interjection
because it is after all a conversation.
It's not a series of handoff monologues.
But I do think that there
was an error of my ways
in that mindset.
Well and I would say that your capacity
to let me talk uninterrupted
is lower than my capacity
for you to talk uninterrupted.
But I think that's a personality thing.
You know what I'm saying?
I just think that I
can kinda, if you spoke
for four minutes without
me saying anything,
there's certain times when
I'll just kinda settle in
and I'm like...
Now listen, let me be very clear.
I like to hear myself talk.
I'm probably perceived
as more of an asshole
than you are to most people.
So I'm not defending myself.
I'm saying and there's
certain aspects about
the way that those conversations come out
that might be like, okay,
Link's gonna tell this story.
If I say anything it's gonna be very,
it's not gonna be derailing.
It's gonna be a little bit additive.
It's not gonna be a different perspective.
It's gonna be like an agreement
or it's gonna be nothing.
And I just don't think
that's your disposition.
I think your disposition is
if I'm gonna say something,
it's gonna be like the ping
pong ball came to my side
of the table for a second.
So whereas I might enter
into more of a hype man sort
of interaction, you enter into
the ball was just volleyed to me.
Let me say something.
That's a little more substantial
and probably a little weird.
Again, I think that's what people like
about your style of comedy.
But I think that's it's
interesting when you apply it
to different types of conversations
'cause I think that...
We both like to tell stories from things
that have happened to us and
I'm not really interested
in like who does more of that or whatever,
'cause I don't know or care,
but I think when it comes
to talking about ideas
or things that aren't like
personal experience type thing,
you'll get on these points about that
and I feel like you're in more of,
that's more of your zone than my zone
and so I do think that there's
an interesting interplay
with how we discuss those type of things
that sometimes it's not like, okay,
you're making a point,
I'm making a counter point back and forth.
I think it's more of like
I'm gonna interject things
and explore it but I'm
not gonna be doing it
in the same way that you are so it's,
and so I think that
there's more opportunity
for me to have interruptions
that couldn't work
in that setting versus
when it's like a story
that we're telling, I don't think that,
I would like to think
I don't do that to you
when it's like, oh, I'm
hearing a tale here,
this is happening.
There's a beginning,
middle, and end so to speak.
It's not an open-ended
conversation whereas
you feel like you're
moving towards this point
or this conclusion but I'm
feeling like we're having
an open-ended conversation.
And I think in that dynamic,
it has led to frustration
for the listener.
Well and I do get,
as a matter of fact, I was,
I don't know how I got here
but I was looking at the
comments on our appearance
the H3H3 podcast which is over a year ago.
Mm-hmm.
And the nature of the
questions that Ethan was asking
were very much about like sort
of like theoretical things
about the YouTube platform and
stuff that just immediately
I have all these thoughts about, right?
Yeah.
And people are like Rhett is
interrupting Link a bunch.
And so like I said, the
haven't beginning of this was,
I think it depends on
the mode of conversation,
whether somebody, whether
you would be like,
well Rhett is interrupting Link
or Link is interrupting Rhett.
'Cause I don't think
this is a one-way thing.
I think that it just kinda
depends on the nature
of what it is that's being discussed
and who's more passionate about it.
And so in terms of, in the
context of Ear Biscuits.
I also don't feel like in those instances
where it's lik there's a
point that you wanna make,
if I do interject, you can get frustrated
because you're trying to make a point
whereas when I talk
about those same things,
I verbally process it more
so I don't necessarily know
the exact point I'm making.
I'm putting it out there
for, having heard it
and discussed it for us to
reach a conclusion together
and I think that's the
different way we approach it.
So I actually don't feel, I
don't think I feel insensitive
to being interrupted when we're talking
about ideas as you do but as
opposed to when it's a story.
So I might be more
sensitive to interrupting
during a story than I
am when I'm interrupting
during an idea conversation.
Yeah.
Well this has become an
interesting conversation.
From your question,
from Mariah's question.
Tips for being a less
obnoxious conversationalist.
Just talk it out.
We turned a lot of, again,
this is one of the reasons
that we interrupt each other
is we turn these questions
into just conversations about ourselves.
We're both--
That's so obnoxious.
We're both mildly narcissistic.
You kinda have to be in this business.
But we--
I don't think
I'm narcissistic.
But we took,
we took the narcissism quiz.
You remember, on the show--
I don't remember.
And we both got the same score.
No I think I'm a psychopath.
No that's sense of smell.
That was a different test.
But we were, there's a
narcissism self-evaluation
that scores you on a scale
of one to 30 or whatever
and it puts different
professions in different places
like in a range.
Leave it to a narcissist
to take a self-evaluation test.
And well we did it for
show and we both scored,
I don't know, I can't
remember the exact number
but it was like a 14 or
whatever which is higher
than the general population
so more narcissistic
than the general population and sort
of the celebrity entertainer range,
we were in the celebrity
entertainer range.
Which is no surprise,
this town's full of self-obsessed people.
That's what makes
Hollywood Hollyweird right?
But we got a little but
of that that kinda got us
into what we do but hopefully not so much
that we're not able to
step back and evaluate it
for the narcissistic, that we can be.
Maybe we helped.
Maybe us making it about ourselves helped,
at least it's...
Just take it for what it's worth.
I mean I had fun talking about you and me.
I'm disturbed, you know...
We'll see, we'll see how it goes.
And I'm gonna be sleeping on
the other side of the bed.
This is not gonna be a good week--
No you can't have that
much change all at once.
It's not gonna be
a good week for me.
You change one thing
at a time.
All right do you have a rec?
I have a quick rec.
This is a little unusual,
it's a product that is not a sponsor
but I am making an effort
to do less meat-based
and animal-based products
in my life and in my food.
Not cutting them out completely but--
For the environment?
You know, there's only
good reasons for it, right?
Environment, greater
ethical reasons, all that.
But one of the ways that
I've incorporated that is
into these, speaking of cooking,
I'd make these scrambles
a lot of times on Saturday
morning with a lot
of the things that we've got in the fridge
so you got eggs and cheese
and some kind of meat
and then mushrooms or onions
or whatever we got right?
Put some hot sauce in it, put
it in a burrito, it's good.
My wife and I like it,
my kids are too picky
so they eat something else.
But I'm slowly moving
towards a place where
that entire scramble,
even down to the eggs is not animal-based
and one of the steps
towards that was the cheese
and this was a big thing
for me was substituting vegan cheese
which I've tried multiple times.
Which is nuts.
No, like literally.
Literally nuts.
But I have found what I
think is a pretty good cheese
that I've tried on a burger as a slice
and also put the shreds in my scramble,
Daiya.
D-A-I-Y-A.
It's one of the most
popular ones that you'll see
when you go to the section
of the grocery store,
but I tried it a couple years
ago and I didn't like it.
I don't know if my tastes have changed
but I think they've
actually reformulated it.
It's getting pretty good.
It's not real cheese.
Is it pricy?
Probably.
He don't even look at the price.
But if you don't eat it next
to regular cheese--
Yeah don't do that.
Don't make that mistake,
don't be an idiot.
Just put it into something that
would normally have cheese.
There's a bunch of different flavors,
a bunch of different presentations
whether they're shredded
or blocks or slices, Daiya.
D-A-Y, D-A-I-Y-A.
I recommend you try it.
Not a sponsor, maybe will be one day.
You said not a sponsor.
Maybe would like
to be a sponsor, I would
like them to be a sponsor.
Daiya if you're listening.
#EarBiscuits, let us know
what you think about this.
You weigh in on the interrupt thing.
I think that's gonna generate
a lot of conversation.
Oh we may have to title it that, Kiko.
Probably.
Probably so.
All right we're up for it.
Thank you for hanging out,
we'll speak at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.